the Joe Rogan experience so what would
you have done say if you had a magic
wand
and you were the president like how do
you how do you mitigate this how do you
this is my biggest frustration with the
White House which is that you have this
populist president who like actually
understands like very much why he got
elected but you have so many has all
these people who work for him
from kind of the old regime basically
was allowed to staff up and those are
the people who were like let's cap the
Paycheck protection program who were
like hey you know we just passed this to
this two point three trillion dollar
plan or what this but let's look wait
and see how it goes as the you know the
unemployment numbers begin to take up
mass small business failure all these
other things and that's the fundamental
tension of the Trump administration is
that there was no like there were no
professional populace so to speak right
like there was no professional apparatus
of people on the right who actually held
and understood why Donald Trump is
president states and this is like this
is what gets back to what I talked about
earlier about the incentive structure
about that system the think tank the
revolving door that is an effort to
maintain power over the policy sphere
because if you control that it doesn't
matter what the people think yeah I mean
matters what happened here's here's why
I was because I mean look he's the
president and he makes his own choices
and if he understood like that there was
this need to go more economically left
and do it then he could he could do it
but the reality is he spent his whole
most of his political capital his first
term like giving a wave tax cuts to
corporations the same thing any other
Republican would have done so that's why
I sort of roll my eyes I don't think he
cares about anything outside of like
winning the day's news cycle I really
don't think he gives a [ __ ] about
anything other than that you know I mean
see this is this is the thing though I
mean I've met Trump you have interviewed
him a couple of times for five to four
times I think and what does he like
exactly what you see exactly what you
see on TV
same guy do you feel like you got
through the layers to talk to a human ya
know because he's always you know my
favorite thing I ever asked Trump I was
like what are people gonna remember you
for
100 years and he's a veteran's choice
and I was like I'm gonna go out on a
limb that's probably not it right Jesus
I'm like sitting in there I occurred
with Mema Trump like I'm in the Oval and
like you're like man that sort of like
Kissinger was sitting like man that's
JFK picture and like Eisenhower's gone I
don't think he thinks about any of them
what did he mean by veterans choice that
he knows the veterans to know that he
was taking care of veterans through like
a veteran's health care going off like
why he would you know like all his
basically like the talking points I'm
like why is great but I realized I'm
like Trump lives completely in the
moment and he doesn't really have that
like he doesn't really think about
things in that historical context well
they say faster in the briefings
he pays attention if his name's brought
up okay they throw his name in there
every now and again
[Laughter]
[Applause]